Transcription: Clare Borradaile
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
La construction d’un bâtiment
a de très forts impacts
sur l’environnement.
Parmi ces impacts,
je m’attacherai à deux d’entre eux
qui sont souvent méconnus
et dont on parle moins :
d’une part, les déblais, notamment
les terres de terrassement
qui font de très gros volumes,
ainsi que le processus
de fabrication et production
de matériaux de construction.
Chacun a dû voir
la construction d’un bâtiment
ou d’un immeuble près de chez lui.
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait,
comment on s’y prend ?
D’abord, on fait un grand trou
et on extrait énormément de matériaux,
de déblais, des terres principalement,
et leurs cailloux, gravier, associés.
Ces déblais sont considérés
comme des déchets.
C’est une problématique
parce que ce sont des déblais naturels
qui n’ont pas d’autres moyens ensuite
que de partir en décharge,
très peu sont recyclés en réalité.
Après ce processus
de terrassement et d’évacuation,
nous allons chercher dans des carrières
des ressources minérales naturelles
pour créer des matériaux de construction,
des granulats principalement,
qui vont devenir des bétons
qui vont devenir des agglomérés de ciment.
Nous transportons tous vers des usines
qui fabriquent ces matériaux
et ensuite nous allons vers des négoces
et ensuite vers les chantiers.
Tout cela crée d’énormes nuisances
et c’est une chaine industrielle
phénoménale
qui émet énormément de carbone,
qui crée beaucoup de pollution
et qui en plus crée
des nuisances de transport
avec tout ce qu’on peut avoir associé.
N'oublions pas les déchets.
On se concentre en fait sur ces déblais,
qui d’habitude sont évacués,
pour les recycler,
en matière de construction,
sur le site-même du projet.
C’est très intéressant
parce qu’ils sont en fait des ressources
et ces ressources,
on peut en faire des matériaux.
Vous voyez à l’écran, par exemple,
des pierres, mortier de terre,
des briques.
Avant, on le faisait à la main.
Aujourd’hui, on peut le faire
avec des machines
ou des blocs ou des bétons
qui permettent finalement de faire
des ouvrages selon leur qualité,
selon ce qu’on veut
obtenir assez facilement.
J’ai écrit sur le slide que c’est un défi.
Pourquoi c’est un défi ?
Parce que c’est vrai que
c’est une démarche ancestrale.
Forcément, on peut me dire:
« vous n’avez rien inventé, monsieur » ,
mais pas du tout.
En fait, les anciens avaient besoin
de bâtiments dans certains usages.
Aujourd’hui, les usages ont changé,
les besoins sont beaucoup plus importants.
On a besoin de réglementaires,
on a besoin d’utiliser des bâtiments
pour d’autres choses qu’avant.
Bref, tout ça a créé
une complexité de règlements,
disons d’usage de sécurité aussi.
Et ça qui crée le défi aujourd’hui,
parce que les matériaux géosourcés,
même s’ils ont fait
leurs preuves dans le passé,
il faut aujourd’hui
les remettre à l’honneur,
et surtout les réappliquer
par rapport aux règlements
qui ne sont pas forcément adaptés
puisqu’ils ont été faits
sur les techniques industrielles.
C’est là les vrais enjeux
et c’est ça que nous faisons
depuis 25 ans chez Filiater.
D’abord par des essais,
des essais de laboratoire
et la collaboration avec
des laboratoires de recherche.
Nous faisons de la recherche,
des avis techniques,
mais on n’a pas fait que ça,
sur ces 25 ans, on a aussi réalisé.
En même temps
qu’on faisait ces essais,
nous avons réalisé des projets
qui ont été exemplaires, expérimentaux,
qui ont permis de démontrer
l’application de cette démarche.
Donc aujourd’hui, on peut parler…
on peut montrer sur cette image,
vous avez un village ancien sur lequel
on a fait une greffe de seize maisons
(ce sont les ouvriers au milieu)
qui ont été construits entièrement
avec les matériaux du site.
On a extrait 1000 mètres cubes
pour les réinjecter complètement
dans les bâtiments, sans évacuation.
Du coup, ces 1000 mètres cubes
ont évité un volume presque équivalent
de matériaux venant d’un autre site,
les carrières et la chaîne
industrielle de tout à l’heure.
Cette expérience a été renouvelée
sur un aurtre projet plus petit mais
où on aussi recyclé 1000 mètres cubes.
Alors 1000 mètres cubes,
c’est quatre piscines olympiques
remplies de terre,
qui sont pas parties vers des décharges
et qui ont été réintroduits
dans les bâtiments.
On peut insister sur un point,
c’est que ces réalisations,
toutes les deux étaient en zone sismique,
ce que nous avons, parce que
nous sommes à Nice ou à Grasse,
c’est pareil, on est en zone sismique.
Dans les deux cas, ces bâtiments
ont été construits sans béton armé.
Le béton armé, très connu pour être
le seul moyen d’assurer le parasismique,
n’a pas été utilisé.
On a pu démontrer
que ces matériaux géosourcés
peuvent répondre aussi à ça.
Et c'est là qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire
qu'il faut passer à aller plus loin.
Et c'est notre notre objectif, c'est
vraiment de passer à la grande échelle.
Cette démarche qu'on a vraiment explorée
et démontrée par ces 25 ans d'expérience
qui nous ont amenés à répondre à un appel
à projets national de l’Ademe
sur lequel on a été lauréat
il y a quelques mois,
pour vraiment nous aider
à passer à la grande échelle.
La grande échelle, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire qu’on va devoir traiter,
on va pouvoir traiter des bâtiments plus
importants, des volumes plus importants
et surtout, j’allais presque dire,
appliquer ça partout dans le monde.
Sur ce projet, nous allons mettre en place
un centre technique spécifique
qui va nous permettre
de poursuivre notre R et D.
Notre R et D est permanente, mais aussi
parce qu’elle nécessite, on va dire,
une application de la démarche
à chaque matériau,
par définition variable.
Partout, on verra
des matériaux différents,
donc il faut s’adapter très rapidement,
comprendre leur comportement
et donc le centre technique
a cet objectif.
À côté de ça, nous allons également
mettre au point des machines,
des équipements,
dont nous avons bien sûr déjà réfléchi,
et certains prototypes,
pour pouvoir recycler, travailler,
traiter les matériaux en grande quantité
pour faire des plus grands volumes,
mais surtout, en permettant de réduire
la pénibilité des travailleurs
pour que ce soit aussi
à la fois facile et économique.
Et ce que j’ai envie de vous dire,
c’est que effectivement,
ces machines vont se déplacer
sur le chantier, elles seront mobiles.
En étant mobiles,
c’est plus du tout
les matériaux qui se déplacent,
ce sont les machines
et les hommes sur les chantiers.
Sur ces deux outils de ce projet,
nous allons les appliquer
à des bâtiments démonstrateurs,
qui font partie du projet
sur les trois ans à venir.
Là, vous avez l’image
de ce qu’on va faire
dans les Bouches-du-Rhône
cette année, en fin d’année.
Il y en a d'autres dans les cartons
et nous en recherchons encore.
Je terminerai par notre image concept,
qui reflète parfaitement la démarche
vertueuse que nous menons pour la planète.
Merci.